bonjour monsieur vesely merci d'être
avec nous ce matin et de répondre à nos
questions sur rt france alors on le
disait un les les éboueurs vont-ils
continuer à ramasser les ordures dans
paris et sa banlieue
quelles sont les conditions actuellement
dans lesquelles travaillent les éboueurs
de la région alors juste je suis pas
directeur je sus traiteur général du
syndicat cgt fcd est 2e à de la ville de
paris qui s'occupe de la filière
traitement traitement des déchets de la
ville de paris donc je ne parlerai que
de paris en tout état de cause paris il
ya dix arrondissements qui sont
connectés en régie donc par des
fonctionnaires territoriaux
ces dix arrondissements a sur nous que i
continueront à être collectées puisque
on veut pas faire une épidémie à la
pandémie actuelle puisque les ordures
ménagères peuvent entraîner d'autres
d'autres maladies sur les dix autres
arrondissements qui sont collectés par
le privé je sais que les salariés des
entreprises privées n'ont pas les mêmes
garanties que nous en terme de sécurité
etc
et c'est là que les choses aillent bon
ben je dis pas qu'elle est de paris
c'est tout est bien en tout et bien mis
en place en tout cas on a on a réussi à
mettre un certain nombre de choses en
place pour que les salariés travaillent
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
et pour garantir leur santé comment
quelle est l'ambiance actuellement chez
les ch et les salariés chez les éboueurs
de la ville de paris est ce que vous
sentez des craintes nier justement à
cette épidémie est aussi à peut-être des
conditions de travail oui bien sur les
épaules de paris sondés sont des
citoyens comme les autres
ici le regard des médias y regarde de
tout ce qui se passe ils ont vu ce qui
s'est passé dans le monde est bien
entendu que ils sont des craintes ou
lola l'auvent en tout cas ils ont des
craintes il ya un certain nombre de
mesures barrières pour éviter de choper
cette maladie
qu'on essaye toutes et tous de faire
cesser ce sont des nouveaux réflexes
apprendrez à connaître et à mettre en
place et je dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de
crainte je dis pas capable
interrogations nous ont tant
qu'organisation syndicale
on essaye de faire le relais entre les
salariés et la direction il habite de
paris les choses se passe plus ou moins
bien en tout cas pour l'instant pas eu
le droit de retrait de demander de la
partie des personnels est ce que la
ville de paris justement mais les
mesures en place nécessaire pour
permettre justement aux éboueurs de
continuer leur travail en toute sécurité
oui mais un certain nombre de mesures
qui si elles sont appliquées par toutes
et à tous
on pense que ça peut éviter des drames
voilà on dit pas qu'il n'y a pas eu de
cas puisque de toute façon des bois
parisiens ils rentrent chez eux ils
reprennent les transports etc
il ya eu je crois une vingtaine de cas
une vingtaine de cas chez les éboueurs
et chez les conducteurs de la ville de
paris de détecter y compris dans leurs
encadrants il ya eu deux cas dans leurs
encadrants la peur n'évite pas le danger
il ya un certain nombre de choses qu'on
ne mesure pas en tout cas il ya mille
éboueur à peu près qui travaille sur la
ville de paris là il ya en régie ajoute
pas il ya près de deux cents 200 200
conducteurs aussi je veux dire que le
les mesures prises aujourd'hui elles
sont peuvent garantir la la bonne des
bonnes pratiques et de remplir nos
missions jusqu'au donc vous nous
rassurer les éboueurs ne vont pas
arrêter du jour au lendemain de
collecter les ordures dans la ville de
paris excusez moi on a voilà donc
c'était régis vieceli elles régissent
vie si vous êtes avec nous oui oui on a
été coupée excusez moi je continue juste
par rapport
notre arrondissement qui sont collectés
par des entreprises privées ces salariés
là par contre n'ont pas les mêmes
garanties
oui et je pense que la maire de paris en
tout cas sur paris elle peut faire
pression puisqu'elle est donneur
d'ordres pression sur ces entreprises
pour que ses salariés les mêmes
garanties que les fonctionnaires
territoriaux de paris pour travailler
dans de bonnes conditions pour que
l'ensemble des ordures ménagères de
paris soit soit déblayé le mieux
possible et quotidiennement merci
beaucoup régis vieceli d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat cgt
propre et merci beaucoup merci